so i'm sorry
yeah
thank you
okay
who's your team okay
um they went inside i was just doing it
on my own you also had an agent yes i
was doing it on my own
come on man what's happening
how's it going guys
you found anything interesting
i think i just got in have you yeah okay
so you just got in at two minutes to go
yeah i know good luck
this is actually one of our okay i found
in coventry last week okay i'll try to
use that one i got everything there nice
nice well yeah good pitch it on pitch it
man hey guys you got anything good
yeah we've got one just another 16
minutes let's have a look um the website
wasn't working so we're using right
we've just done it manually fair play
man fair play man
it doesn't look amazing but
yeah a lot of people have said that
about the website okay a little bit of
little bit of work needed probably needs
a few grand 65 sheffield
what's the rent 550.
solid wanted a few thousand probably
about 18 19 roi yeah solid guys remember
to pitch it when if you if you're going
on stage in your picture just just say
i've budgeted a three grand refurb
hey guys i found anything
nice where was it it's
scotland oh wow i love it well done are
you guys okay we've got one higher cost
i've previously reviewed this before um
it's the 50k one on duke's present i put
it off of 44 and 300. nice they didn't
accept it i've just called him again i
don't know if he's still on the market
um basically
if he was going to do it
there's a bit of work doing to it yeah
yeah but how do you budget that in the
in the uh yeah the street next the next
streak is ten pounds
getting ready to pitch man get ready to
pitch
you guys got something good
yeah 130 127 pound feet turn off
investment 11
okay
deposit of 13k where is how much the
rent on it uh
hang on that'll make sense if it's 500 a
month
and if the rent's 500 and he's on for 55
yeah
is it on auction he doesn't see it
and he says no on your chain as well in
that case the roi will be much higher
than you think man would it be 11 no it
would be higher if you buy that for 55
grand
[Music]
and you rent that for 500 yeah six grand
a month right the roi on that is going
to be a lot higher is it yeah sale it's
for sale
uh i'm trying to rent out to up other
people
and uh i'm an investor
it's for sale
oh it's book
i just want to book a view in look at
the property and then uh
are you looking for property to buy
yes
right now i thought you meant you wanted
to rent one of our properties
[Music]
you know what though when you get
uncomfortable
what happens is you get comfortable
being uncomfortable
so that was your first time calling
right yeah yeah
respect how old are you i'm 19. 19 years
old to be honest the house that i'm
living in right now with my parents i'm
the one that called and arranged a
meeting and were literally uh
renting out the house
there we go but she was like asking
you're like oh what do you mean what do
you mean renting out and all this and
you're a bit like
didn't know what to say you came a bit
too yeah but what did you what did you
learn
i mean you gotta be prepared not gonna
lie you gotta be prepared and uh
you go
you gotta act like you actually wanna
buy the house right you gotta act
interesting yes she's trying to sell it
i'd be hungry for it yeah she's trying
to sell it you're ringing up saying i
want to buy it perfect fit
you know what i'm saying but the thing
is making calls a lot of people 19 years
old won't do what you just did yeah most
people are 19 years old they wouldn't
even pick up the phone because i don't
want to do that i'll let you do it you
do it whatever but the fact that you
made the call to the agent yeah did you
say to him doing it your hands do it and
then you're saying to himself but you
did it so respect for your courage all
right i hope you get the deal well done
jordan big respect coming up so jordan
what happened in the in those 20 minutes
what happened to you okay so i rang up
the agency and uh this lady was
like kind of straightforward she was
asking bear questions
so i would say you you gotta be really
prepared for this
and um
how many how many were in your group
sorry how many were in your group
there's three of us three of you so you
found a potential lead
and then the the the dude in your group
was like passed it over to the woman in
the group to make the call and then the
woman in the group passed it over to you
and no one wanted to pick up the phone
how many years it takes courage to ring
an agent yes or no
right so
jordan's like i'll do it rings up the
agent
and he says he says hey i'm just ringing
uh and he froze
is that what happened yeah that's true
right she froze and then she went what
what hello anyway oh yeah um
i'm looking to rent it
and she said
said rent what
are you looking to rent
i'm looking to rent it
jim what is this true yeah that's true
and then
i came over i heard what was going on so
i muted i muted the phone i said say bye
to that you're looking to buy to let and
he went back to that and then oh bye
i had a nice conversation and she's
going to give him a call back however
you said to me like oh man that was hard
however
what's the only way to grow it is to
grow yourself and the only way to grow
yourself is to step out of your comfort
zone did you step out your comfort zone
yeah massively yeah so well done well
done so question
so question did you think this morning
that when you woke up
you'd be
on the phone pitching agents and sharing
what happened in front of over 200
people in london
how old are you i'm 19 19 and what's
your uh what's your goal why are you
here
well um i want to be surrounded by
successful people yeah and uh i want to
push myself because i'm hungry to be
successful
right
all right good good
how many of you have a feeling that
jordan's going to be wildly successful
right now say aye
dude i'll remember you bro i'm watching
for you to win anyway i can help you hit
me up give him a big hand it's jordan